polonia es uno de los países más
importantes de europa del este- tal y
como os hemos contado aquí en visual
político un vídeo que os dejo en la
descripción su proceso de crecimiento y
desarrollo durante las últimas décadas
ha sido vertiginoso
desde el año 1992 la economía polaca ha
crecido una media de más del 4% anual a
nivel europeo polonia ha sido el país
más próspero tan solo por detrás de
irlanda estonia y letonia de hecho
aunque pueda resultar sorprendente dadas
sus circunstancias históricas pero lo
cierto es que los polacos se sitúan ya
en la media europea en cuanto a riesgo
de pobreza
es decir en otras palabras polonia ha
sido uno de los países que mejor ha
sabido digerir la transición política
económica y social a la que los antiguos
países de la órbita soviética se
tuvieron que enfrentar tras el colapso
de la unión soviética
sin embargo amigos el esperado momento
porque no es oro todo lo que reluce los
números las magnitudes los datos
económicos son muy buenos si de eso no
hay la menor duda en ese aspecto el
éxito es innegable pero qué sucede en el
terreno político y social
pues amigos a ellas cuando nos
encontramos que las cosas dejan de ser
de color de rosas especialmente si os
preocupan las libertades civiles ya
sabéis eso de que es más fácil cambiar
una economía que una sociedad lo segundo
lleva mucho más tiempo
el caso es que como vamos a ver polonia
es probablemente junto a hungría el país
más conservador y tradicionalista de
toda la unión europea una prueba el
cristianismo es parte de nuestra
identidad nacional la iglesia fue y es
el predicador y el soporte del único
sistema de valores comúnmente sostenido
en polonia fuera de eso sólo hay
nihilismo jaroslaw kaczynski ex primer
ministro y presidente del partido en el
gobierno ley injusticia pero no sólo eso
también es un país que se ha
caracterizado por impulsar una agenda
política que para muchos choca
directamente con los principios de la
unión europea queréis conocer más a
fondo qué diantres ocurre en polonia
como de conservadora de su sociedad cuál
es esa agenda que se ha convertido en
toda una pesadilla un dolor de cabeza
para las autoridades europeas pues
atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
amigos de visual política en polonia si
no eres católico blanco y heterosexual
entonces creo que vas a tener un
problema lo más seguro es que de una
forma u otra te sientas rechazado por
buena parte de la sociedad y si también
por el gobierno el partido oficialista
de polonia aviva el sentimiento anti el
gp antes de las elecciones elecciones
polacas el líder del partido mayoritario
apunta a los derechos de los
homosexuales como una amenaza para la
sociedad en este país el rechazo a todo
lo que escapa el modelo tradicional de
familia cristiana está muy presente en
la sociedad por ejemplo en la mayoría de
países europeos que el partido en el
gobierno o tilde de amenaza para la
sociedad a las personas lgtbi sería algo
impensable sin embargo aquí es algo que
está a la orden del día
simplemente polonia es así
ahora bien como puede un país como este
que en cierto modo promueve el acoso a
minorías encajar en un proyecto como el
de la unión europea ese es el gran
dilema
la política polaca resulta en ocasiones
difícil de entender por un lado los
polacos eligen y se eligen a un partido
nacionalista anti inmigración y homófobo
es decir que se enfrenta a todo lo que
aparentemente significa el proyecto
comunitario para dirigir el país pero
por otro lado la sociedad polaca es una
de las que tiene mejor impresión de la
unión europea fijaos
[Música]
pero que una cosa es tener una impresión
positiva de la unión europea' y otra muy
diferente es estar dispuestos a cumplir
con las directrices que emanan de
bruselas fijaos fijaos como mandan las
cosas el tribunal de justicia de la
unión europea polonia rompió la ley de
la unión europea con la reforma judicial
polonia y hungría rompen la ley de la ue
al rechazar acoger inmigrantes los
tribunales advierten
polonia desafía a bruselas prometiendo
adherirse al carbón polonia prioriza a
frenar su dependencia de la energía rusa
y continuar con su dependencia del
carbón en lugar de suscribirse al
objetivo de cero emisiones de la unión
europea en un movimiento que pondrá a
varsovia rumbo a un choque frontal
contra bruselas en política climática
vamos que mucha unión europea y tal pero
a la hora de la verdad polonia vapor
libre pero entonces como puede ser que
la imagen que los polacos tienen de la
web sea tan buena vamos a responder a
esta pregunta pero vayamos paso a paso
porque creedme cuando os digo que la
política polaca es una verdadera locura
[Música]
hace ya más de dos años que en bruselas
saltaron todas las alarmas por la
supuesta deriva antidemocrática de
polonia si lo habéis escuchado bien
podría estar polonia experimentando un
viraje hacia el autoritarismo
respondamos a esta pregunta
[Música]
con los tonos o democracia o porque no
gracias
votar es además y allá
[Música]
en la democracia polaca en jaque
hay una cosa mucho pero que mucho más
importante que la lealtad de polonia a
la unión europea me estoy refiriendo a
la salud de la democracia y lo cierto es
que hoy por hoy la democracia polaca no
está pasando por sus mejores momentos y
eso eso sí que es preocupante
lo que más ha hecho sonar las alarmas ha
sido la deriva cada vez más personalista
del gobierno por la que hay está por
ejemplo el intento de jaroslaw kaczynski
el líder del partido oficialista por
reducir la edad de jubilación de los
jueces del tribunal supremo- desde los
70 hasta los 65 años lo que supondría
echar a la calle al 40% de ellos
previsiblemente para ser sustituidos por
otros afines al partido este cambio fue
paralizado por el tribunal europeo de
justicia por considerarlo como un claro
intento de control político sobre el
poder judicial sin embargo a pesar de
ello el gobierno ha continuado avanzando
en esa misma dirección por muchas vías
diferentes
en 2017 por ejemplo el gobierno logró
que se aprobaran en el parlamento otras
tres leyes muy pero que muy polémicas
toda una apuesta personal de kaczynski
para controlar el país literalmente nada
ni nadie se le iban a poner por delante
[Música]
básicamente entre las tres leyes se
pretendía no solo otorgar a los
legisladores enormes poderes sobre el
consejo general del poder judicial sino
también que el propio ministro de
justicia que por cierto también es el
fiscal general fuera quien nombras a los
jueces y a los jefes de los tribunales
locales ya os podéis imaginar lo que
supondría esto en términos de control
político sobre los tribunales sobre la
justicia
pero no un giro inesperado de los
acontecimientos el presidente del país
andrei duda afín al partido oficialista
pero no perteneciente al partido veto
poco después dos de esas tres leyes
permitiendo únicamente el nombramiento
de los jefes de los tribunales locales
por el ministro de justicia
pero aquí no termina todo para nada la
obsesión del gobierno por controlar la
justicia es algo constante bolonia está
purgando sus fiscales la cámara
disciplinaria para los jueces polacos no
es independiente según un asesor
superior del tribunal superior de
justicia de la unión europea
y claro llegados a este punto muchos
pensaréis y que está haciendo la web
mientras tanto pues casi podemos decir
que las autoridades comunitarias han
abierto una batalla frontal contra
polonia por todas estas cuestiones de
hecho bruselas activo por primera vez en
su historia el mecanismo de acción
disciplinaria contra un país miembro
algo que podría terminar con la
suspensión del derecho a voto de polonia
en las decisiones europeas
polonia es llevado ante la corte europea
de justicia por presunto control
político de la justicia y que queréis
que os diga motivos parece que sobran
eso de ver a los políticos metiendo mano
en la justicia es algo muy pero que muy
preocupante ahora bien los
enfrentamientos no sólo se limitan a
este intento del gobierno polaco de
asaltar sus propios tribunales
con la separación de poderes
si a todo esto le sumamos las políticas
de tinte xenófobo ultracatólico y
homófobo del partido en el gobierno
entonces entonces lo que nos encontramos
es con un país que se enfrenta de raíz
el rumbo que ha tomado la unión europea
durante los últimos años
polonia golpe a los inmigrantes pero
silenciosamente recibe a los cristianos
los progresistas temen disturbios
mientras la iglesia católica polaca
dobla su retórica anti grey
el arzobispo de cracovia describió a
polonia como asediada por una plaga
arcoiris de activistas por los derechos
de los gays que comparó con los antiguos
gobernantes comunistas de polonia en las
próximas elecciones por la cas el
partido ley y justicia está demonizando
a la comunidad lgtb para ganar vamos que
tal y como veis los rumbos políticos de
la unión europea y de polonia se parecen
tanto como un huevo a una castaña
pero claro llegados a este punto os
preguntaréis pero alberto entonces por
qué demonios los polacos tienen una
imagen tan buena de la unión europea
pues amigos lo cierto es que no todo lo
que tiene que ver con la unión europea
si os gusta tanto al partido en el
gobierno y por ende a la sociedad polaca
hay algo que pare
en cantarles atentos
[Música]
y dinero a todos nos gusta el dinero
y amigos yo no es que sea el mayor fan
de la unión europea tal y como está
montada pero es que los polacos se
llevan la palma cumplir con las
normativas comunitarias en materia de
garantías políticas y judiciales
respetar a las minorías o aceptar a los
6.200 solicitantes que a bruselas
asignó a polonia en el reparto
comunitario de refugiados no de eso nada
ni ninguna manera pero el dinero ahí el
dinero eso eso ya es otra cosa el dinero
de la ue por supuesto que es bien
recibido he recibido con los brazos bien
abiertos y una enorme sonrisa y es que
no hablamos precisamente de calderilla
[Música]
desde que polonia se integró la unión
europea ha recibido más de 110 mil
millones de dólares en ayudas
comunitarias tan solo el fondo de
cohesión europeo ha otorgado a polonia
más de 85 mil millones de dólares para
el periodo 2014-2020 con el fin de
financiar proyectos de infraestructuras
como por ejemplo autopistas y
ferrocarriles y es que de hecho polonia
es de todos los países de la web que
reciben dinero del fondo de cuestión de
los que más reciben por cierto frente a
lo que se suele decir este tipo de
ayudas no han sido la clave ni mucho
menos del despegue económico polaco para
nada pero es verdad que sí que lo han
apoyado
y es aquí cuando surge una pregunta que
cada vez más líderes políticos de la
unión europea se hacen debería la unión
europea acondicionar las ayudas
comunitarias a que los países receptores
acepten cumplir con las propias normas y
resoluciones de la unión debería
bruselas congelar los fondos destinados
a estados miembros con gobiernos anti
liberales populistas y que no cumplan
con sus responsabilidades pues parece
que por ahí pueden ir los tiros
bruselas le dice a polonia que la unión
europea no es una vaca que pueda ordeñar
y en cierto modo tiene sentido no os
parece el caso es que justo ahora se
están terminando de negociar los
términos y el reparto del fondo de
cohesión de la unión europea para el
periodo 2021 2027 y parece que polonia
podría no salir bien parada
polonia recibirá un 23 por ciento menos
del presupuesto de la unión europea 2020
2027 de esta forma de confirmarse esta
noticia polonia podría perder casi una
cuarta parte del dinero que recibe de la
unión europea aunque eso sí con algo más
de eso
cuatro mil millones de dólares seguiría
siendo el mayor receptor de fondos de
cohesión pero ahora bien no es lo que
estáis pensando
este recorte no tiene nada que ver con
un castigo ni nada por el estilo sino
con el hecho de que polonia tal y como
os contábamos al principio de este vídeo
es hoy un país más rico con mejores
infraestructuras y está más próximo a la
media de desarrollo del resto de la
unión europea
[Música]
con eso y con que el break city ha
obligado a bruselas a ajustar
ligeramente el cinturón ya no puede
contar con la aportación que cada año
hacía el reino unido- las arcas
comunitarias
[Música]
en cualquier caso esto es algo que abre
un interrogante de la tendencia política
de la sociedad polaca y su enorme
distancia con el rumbo marcado por
bruselas no supondrá la reducción de
fondos a polonia que poco a poco este
país se vaya alejando de la unión no
explotaran los partidos nacionalistas
polacos estos recortes como una prueba
de la intromisión comunitaria y la
pregunta más importante de todas son las
políticas polacas y húngaras las
políticas de europa del este-
compatibles con la unión europea
dejadnos vuestras respuestas en los
comentarios si este vídeo os ha
resultado interesante y darle al botón
de like y por supuesto suscribiros
abisal politics si aún no lo habéis
hecho un saludo y hasta la próxima
gracias por todo gracias botones de
masisa